There is no corner of this world you have not explored. No geography of the soul which you cannot navigate.
Mr. Shakespeare,
I don't want to pester you, good
Excellent news cheerio. I just wanted to ask you, the best way to get started as a writer is to start writing
No, really could I just. I don't have a favourite play
I admire all my fellow dramatists equally and yes
I do think women should be allowed to perform the female roles as is the practice on the continent now, please if you'll excuse me
Father, why are you come home? No more stories left to write? I've lived so long in imaginary worlds
I think I've lost sight of what is real.
Will, it's Sunday.
You miss Church here, they'll fine you
Your talent has a greater scope than all the other poets, and yet you've lived the smallest life.
Family is everything, it's love not ambition that will blossom in this garden. Well, something has to. I'm not a good gardener. It's true.
My husband thinks you've come home to die
I've just bought a pension. I can't die for at least 10 years or I'll be ruined.
You went to London and became this great writer with a wife at home. You were hardly here. To us you're a guest
Good night husband
Retirement hasn't exactly brought the peace we might have hoped for
You must write again Will, people need you.
My soul is empty.
Your soul is not empty father, your soul has the whole world in it.
Why, why did you stop writing?  I've never let the truth get in the way of a good story
All these years worried about your reputation
Have you even once considered mine?
Through my genius I've brought fame and fortune to this house! I'm the head of this family!
And if you're honest with yourself, then whatever you write...
All is true